في وقت مبكر من صباح يوم الخميس
، هجوم على بلدة تقع غربي
العاصمة الأوكرانية ، تواصل روسيا
قصفها للبنية التحتية الرئيسية لأوكرانيا في
جميع أنحاء البلاد ،
مثل هذا المشهد في وسط أوكرانيا ، وهو
مشهد شائع لحطام محطات توليد الطاقة.
شوهدت طائرات كاميكازي بدون طيار بعد
هجوم على الجانب الآخر من البلاد
في هاركيف رخيصة ذاتية التفجير وغير
مأهولة ، فهي سلاح جديد في
حرب روسيا على أوكرانيا ، تشير العلامات إلى
geran II ، لكن هذا ليس سلاحًا روسيًا ،
اسمه من تصميم شاهد
وصُنعت في إيران ، تُعرف
بالذخيرة المتساقطة ، يمكن أن تدور حول
هدف ويمكن أن يسافر هيكل الطائرة خفيف الوزن
لمسافات طويلة
، وتقول الحكومة الأمريكية إن وفدًا روسيًا
سافر إلى إيران في يونيو
لتفقد الطائرات بدون طيار التي شوهدت هنا في
صور الأقمار الصناعية التي حصلت
عليها سي إن إن حصريًا في الأسابيع الأخيرة
صعدت روسيا بشكل كبير من استخدامها
لأدلة الطائرات المسيرة المنشورة
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الأوكرانية بشكل شبه يومي  على أساس
أن العدو يحاول إنقاذ
أنواع مختلفة من العيارات من صواريخ كروز ، فإن هذه
الرؤوس أرخص بكثير أولاً ،
ويمكن استخدامها بشكل متكرر أكثر ،
وهي تعمل في أزواج ،
وتستخدم أوكرانيا أيضًا طائرات Kamikaze بدون طيار
مثل Switchblade الأصغر بكثير المصنعة في الولايات المتحدة على
الرغم من عدم وجود دليل
على ذلك  تشير إلى أن أوكرانيا استخدمت السلاح
ضد أي شيء عدا الأهداف العسكرية
[موسيقى]
لقد نجح الدفاع الجوي الأوكراني إلى حد ما
في استخدام الطائرات بدون طيار التابعة لروسيا في داونينج ،
لكن حقيقة أنها رخيصة جدًا
لأن الأوكرانيين قلقون ويلعبون دورًا كبيرًا
في مساعيهم هذا الأسبوع لمزيد من
الغرب  المساعدة في الدفاع الجوي
قال الرئيس الأوكراني زيلينسكي إن
روسيا طلبت 2400 طائرة بدون طيار من طراز كاميكازي
من إيران ، ويخشى المسؤولون هنا من أنه مع
استهداف روسيا بشكل متزايد للمراكز السكانية ، أصبحت
طائرات كاميكازي جزءًا متزايدًا
من نسخة أرسنال المقلدة من سي إن إن كييف